[Music]
from ally mcbeal to arrested development
porsha darasi used to regularly grace
our tv screens
however in recent years she's retreated
from the spotlight
here's a closer look at why you rarely
see porsha derasi these days
de rossi had a long journey to reach
full self-acceptance
one of her first steps on this path was
the empowering act of giving herself her
own distinctive name
portia de rossi was born in australia as
amanda rogers
although less memorable than her chosen
moniker her birth name wasn't
incompatible with fame
but the rebranding went much deeper than
careerism
darasi has commented that changing her
name at 15
reflected her struggle to reconcile her
sexuality
with an as yet unaccepting world as she
told the advocate
in retrospect i think it was largely due
to my struggle about being gay
everything just didn't fit and i was
trying to find things i could identify
myself with
and it started with my name she picked
her first name porsha from shakespeare's
the merchant of venice
and chose de rossi because it sounded
exotic and sophisticated to her
de rossi started out in commercials
before transitioning to a few
small silver screen roles at that time
she was a young student at the
university of melbourne studying for a
career in law
her first credit was in a low-budget
australian comedy called
sirens that came out in 1994. though de
rossi's role was not a main one
the film received attention because it
was one of three films released that
year that raised hugh grant's profile
with american audiences
in 1998 de rossi landed the part of nell
porter in ally mcbeal
this character was known as the ice
queen while also serving as a form of
comic relief
an early example of de rossi's talent
for playing difficult personalities to
humorous effect
in order to both create her own identity
and cement her career as a respected
american
television actress de rossi had to
demonstrate a colossal level of
commitment
one of the pivotal moments in her life
was her marriage to filmmaker mel
metcalfe in 1996
by this time de rossi was a rising star
and wanted to stake a permanent claim in
hollywood
to do that she needed a green card her
marriage served the dual function of
securing her future
as well as veiling her struggle with her
sexuality de rossi says she couldn't go
through with a green card scheme in the
end but the fact that she considered the
option is a testament to how important
her career was to her
at least back then she took all kinds of
transformative measures to solidify her
hollywood reputation
even training herself out of her
australian accent while living in los
angeles and then i'm going to be
trailblazer of the year
portia de rossi's career commitment had
to weather some pretty heavy
discouragement over the years
as some of her career choices didn't go
so well maybe the weight of her
disappointments eventually took their
toll
and led to her disappearing from
hollywood altogether
as we've seen in the case of arrested
development quality doesn't always
equate to wide viewership
the surreal satirical sitcom better off
ted
starred de rossi and began airing in
2009
when porsha was fresh off a recurring
role in the successful medical drama
niptuck sadly better off ted was
canceled the next year
despite praise from critics and a cult
following that was unfortunately
too small of course some of her ventures
were clear missteps such as mr sterling
which only made it two months and 10
episodes before being cancelled
de rossi's attempts at crossing over to
film were mostly unsuccessful as well
she appeared in australian production
the night we called it a day
the poorly reviewed wes craven flick
cursed
and a few made-for-tv movies in addition
to the aforementioned failures
some of de rossi's endeavors never had
the chance to get off the ground
one in particular that we would have
loved to see had nbc not pulled the plug
was a potential monsters reboot all the
way back in 2012.
from the looks of its pilot it could
have been a hit it also would have
constituted a bit of a reboot for her
career
after producers decided better off ted
was better off dead
instead the show's cancellation was both
costly and conspicuous
it's so horrible and it's not true it's
easy
to imagine darasia's lily munster in
mockingbird lane
the first episode of which aired as a
halloween special in 2012.
it had the option for a series pickup as
well as a huge budget
and years of planning but nbc declined
robbing us of yet another hilarious
porsche de rossi character
lily munster is a literal vampire but
unlike the cold dead personality for
which the mythical species is known
the elegant lily is benevolent toward
humans
and deeply loving and caring toward her
family if this high profile spot had
stuck
we might be seeing more of de rossi
today
while many of de rossi's projects are
critically loved for their uniqueness
and cleverness
they don't always fare well enough with
audiences to avoid cancellation
outside of arrested development de
rossi's most recent appearance on
television was in 2017.
she played another quintessential
porsche character in a guest appearance
on netflix's santa clarita diet
when she portrayed a socially awkward
doctor who spends so much time studying
the dead
that she's forgotten how to interact
with living people
this critically acclaimed cult favorite
began at 78 percent on rotten tomatoes
and climbed 11 points each season for a
100
rating in season 3 which is when netflix
decided to cancel it
though de rossi hadn't had a huge role
at that time critics called her the
show's secret weapon
unfortunately this saga reads like so
many of her ventures that deserved
better
her roles are an acquired taste perhaps
because she presents us with traits
we're supposed to hate
and forces us to love her anyway de
rossi's roles represent her own
unapologetic authenticity and her later
successes attest to that
in neptuck she played the mother of
villain eden lorde
remaining loyal to her despite knowing
what she's done
and on scandal de rossi was a strong
intelligent woman who did whatever it
took to get what she wanted
in addition to showcasing her
versatility as a formidable comedic and
dramatic actress
these roles showcase her strength as a
person despite a preference for privacy
she has used her status as a celebrity
to become a voice for many vulnerable
populations
she opened up about her struggle with an
eating disorder in her book
unbearable lightness a story of loss and
gain
and is also an active champion of animal
rights
as one of the first openly gay women in
hollywood
she led courage to members of the lgbtq
plus community
it was a challenging road to
self-acceptance for a long time she
refused to publicly discuss her
relationships or sexual orientation
she opened up about her private life
only after she began dating ellen
degeneres in 2004
de rossi is very aware that while she
didn't choose to be gay
living her life as an openly gay woman
was a choice she had to make
while it appeared that dorasi's decision
to taken her on an upward trajectory
leaving her with a successful television
career and a loving relationship
something happened in 2017 that threw
her career into question
when her dynamic character on scandal
went out with a bang
killed in her office with a golf club
elizabeth north's death was a
notoriously shocking one for the series
when someone leaves a show in such
dramatic fashion fans are often inclined
to wonder whether there is something
deeper going on
was hollywood done with porsha for good
part of the shock factor derived from
the gruesomeness of the killing
but most of it sprang from the fact that
no one saw it coming
many deaths and drama series come as
surprises but de rossi had just been
elevated from recurring character to
series regular
in the previous season it seemed like
things were looking up
and that she was becoming an
indispensable character de rossi was
only the second series regular to be
killed off the show
according to an interview she gave with
showrunner shonda rimes after her
character was killed off
it was de rossi who made the decision to
leave the two have nothing but good
things to say about each other
rhymes describes herself as a long time
fan of de rossi's and wishes she could
hang on to her forever
meanwhile the act revealed that she
loved scandal but chose to leave because
she found a new career direction she was
excited about
of which rhymes was totally supportive
and so de rossi left hollywood
quietly she since revealed that it was
her choice to retire
not just from scandal but from acting as
a whole
she spoke more about this decision on
the ellen degeneres show
explaining that as she approached 45
years old she began to take stock of her
life
and what challenges she could take on
that she hadn't before
especially since she had a pretty good
idea of what acting would continue to
look like for her
this quiet exit is on brand for porsha
de rossi who despite her openness about
some aspects of her life
has a record of being pretty quiet in
public commentary
in her interview with degeneres the
couple commented on de rossi's aversion
to press and talk shows
de rossi has said that her private life
is hers and hers alone
but the media tries to get as close a
look into celebrity relationships and
homes as they possibly can
as the actor explained on her wife's
show about the only thing you can
control
is how you respond publicly de rossi has
certainly exercised a great deal of
control over her own public actions and
reactions
even when controversy erupts around her
for example
she was noticeably absent when the new
york times sat down with the other major
cast members of arrested development
to discuss the accusations of sexual
misconduct and verbal abuse against
jeffrey tambor
she was also mostly silent when her
spouse became the focus of a toxic
workplace scandal in 2020
degeneres has since described the
quietly supportive derasi
as her rock during that time dorasi's
understated personality
might be why you still see her in a bit
of arrested development season 5.
de rossi once joked that creator mitch
hurwitz essentially
ignored her when she quit and wrote her
into the fifth season anyway
she and hurwitz had a good supportive
conversation when she quit
and then suddenly she was in five more
episodes but that's all right with her
de rossi explained that arrested
development the show she loves so much
and whose cast she has referred to as
her other family
is the only exception to her retirement
from acting but the actress appears in
only a handful of episodes in the fifth
season
and most of these appearances are pretty
odd to say the least
as fans quickly noticed her scenes are
mostly green screened in this season
lindsay bluth also develops the habit of
covering herself with a sheet
which means that de rossi is largely
hidden from view in a few scenes
basically she's as distant from
hollywood as she can possibly be
porsha darasi is still quite the
celebrity but she has now capitalized on
her art appreciation to start a high-end
art printing business an online gallery
called
general public whereas her iconic
character on arrested development had
the habit of pursuing new careers and
pioneering obscure charitable events
without much forethought
de rossi put a lot of thought and effort
into her venture
even teaming up with fujifilm to create
a new 3d technology the general public
uses to print its recreations
she's also involved in a lot of
philanthropy especially animal related
from the best friends animal society to
the gentle barn
she and her wife are responsible for the
ellen degeneres wildlife fund
and the two traveled to rwanda in 2019
to officially break ground
on the ellen degeneres campus of the
dianne fosse gorilla fund
if you see a gorilla just don't point at
it
it's safe to say derasi has stayed busy
even as she takes her creative talents
in a new direction
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite celebs are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one